a visit here a promise there and never
far away from a cheesy photo op Boris
Johnson's first month as Prime Minister
felt like the campaign never finished
crisscrossing the country but unlike his
predecessors not Criss crossing the
continent until this week with visits to
Berlin tomorrow and Paris on Thursday
for the first face-to-face encounters
with the main EU leaders it won't be a
warm welcome
having digested the four-page letter
from Boris Johnson to EU Council
President Donald Tusk demanding the
removal of the backstop last night the
EU gave it the thumbs down on Twitter
Donald Tusk said those against the
backstop and not proposing realistic
alternatives in fact support
re-establishing a border even if they do
not admit it by mid-afternoon
tit-for-tat exchanges were being fired
both ways across the channel it is
absolutely true that our friends and
partners are a bit negative many were
getting you know I saw what Donald Tusk
had to say and it you know it wasn't
redolent of you know a sense of optimism
but I think actually will get them I
think there is a real sense now that
something needs to be done with this
backstop we can't get it through
Parliament as it is but ahead of
tomorrow's meeting Angela Merkel managed
to sound more positive albeit without
promising changes to the withdrawal
agreement I've always said that when one
has the will to find these solutions one
can do so in a short period of time the
EU is ready to find a solution but for
that there is no need to reopen the
withdrawal agreement it's a question of
future ties Britain needs to decide
which way it goes
[Music]
ministers aren't busying themselves
thinking about alternatives to the
backstop because they think the blockage
in the negotiations is much closer to
home they think Brussels is watching to
see whether MPs do what protesters up
and down Whitehall demand day-in day-out
and stop brexit altogether if they don't
then they hope the EU will engage more
constructively along the lines Boris
Johnson is suggesting buried in Boris
Johnson's four-page letter to Donald
Tusk were lots of clues about how he
might pursue brexit he wants a more
distant relationship with the EU for
instance than the warned envisaged by
Teresa May giving himself the ability to
pull away from EU standards on products
on Environmental Protection's and on
workers rights he's also not a fan of
international agreements meaning it'll
be harder for the EU to enforce
guarantees made by Britain in this set
of negotiations but will it be enough
for Tory brexit ears but even if Boris
Johnson pulls off the seemingly
impossible and gets the e to drop the
Irish backstop this may not be enough
for some of his own I will have to take
a long pragmatic look at whatever the EU
offers the Prime Minister this is this
is now a high-stakes game and I think
it'll come down to the margins with
criticism growing mps are demanding a
say but Parliament is on holiday for
another fortnight and the government is
just ignoring recalled petitions like
this one as he prepares to fly to Berlin
tomorrow however Boris Johnson won't be
able to avoid the unvarnished ease of EU
neighbors any longer Sam Cade Sky News